Tests, tests, tests.
Die Welt besteht aus Tests. Eigentlich ist man die ganze Zeit nur am Testen. Wenn man es nicht immer wieder ausprobiert, dann wird es nicht besser.
Ja, wie wärs denn mal mit einer Sendung zum Testen? Wie wärs denn mal mit einer Sendung zum Testen?
Hello, hier ist Chaos Radio express, die dritte Ausgabe live aus dem Wohnzimmer. Ihr werdet es schon gemerkt haben. Genau, wenn man nämlich eine gute Sendung aufnehmen will, dann muss man auch mal testen. Und zum Testen hab ich jetzt auch meinen ersten Ad-hoc-Gast, nämlich Pavel.
Hallo.
Genau, teste doch mal bitte, ob das Mikrofon funktioniert.
Eins, zwei, drei, Test.
Es funktioniert, super. Ich hab jetzt keine Ahnung, ob das Lautstärke-Verhältnis gut ist, aber das kriegen wir bestimmt nachher noch korrigiert. Wie ist denn das bei dir so mit Testen? Testest du viel?
Oh, ich habe ein gutes Verhältnis zu Tests in jeder Hinsicht. Vor allen Dingen, Testen ist natürlich mühsam. Und wenn man immer wieder testen will, ist natürlich die Frage, inwieweit man das Testen auch automatisieren kann. Und deswegen automatische Tests sind natürlich die besten Tests.
Aber... Aber ich meine, man fängt ja nicht gleich mit der Automatisierung von Tests an. Wenn zunächst einmal muss man sicher auch etwas erarbeiten, was man dann automatisieren möchte, weil man kann nicht irgendwas beliebiges automatisieren.
Nein, das ist sicher richtig. Das mit den Testen fängt natürlich irgendwann dann an, wenn man auch etwas zum Funktionieren bringen will und auf die Nase gefallen ist, weil sich irgendwelche Mängel offenbart haben, weil man nicht genug getestet hat und das zu einer ziemlichen Unzeit. Gerade wenn man auf der Bühne steht und irgendwelche Shows macht, stell dir vor, diese Software würde jetzt einfach abstürzen. Ja, und stell dir jetzt vor, wir würden auf einer Bühne stehen und vor uns würden jetzt 2000 Menschen darauf warten, irgendetwas Nettes zu hören und dann losgehen und keiner kann es hören.
The presentation should be running in 5 minutes. I just have to install my new operating system.
Und alles nur wegen zu wenig testen.
Genau. Auch diese Sendung ist ein Test. Ihr hört schon, wir testen hier so allerlei, aber wir reden auch über Tests.
Genau, und es ist übrigens mitten spät früh in der Nacht zur Unzeit sozusagen.
Genau, wir vollkommen unkorrekt eingestellten einzelnen Komponenten. Aber wir haben Freude daran, die Maschine hier ein bisschen zum Spielen zu bringen, damit sie immer im richtigen Moment das Richtige tut. Zum Beispiel teste ich jetzt hier mal kurz, jetzt teste ich mal was, 1, 2, 3, 4, das müsste eigentlich der sein. Aufgepasst? Das war ein bisschen zu laut.
Ja, aber du sagst es dir, das kann man später alles noch ändern, optimieren, anpassen. Genau wie die Tests auch selber. Wenn du Tests automatisierst, was sind dann das für Tests primär? Naja, wenn Software immer komplizierter wird und man irgendwann noch tatsächlich sie weiterentwickeln will und nicht nur Fehlern hinterherjagen, dann muss das das Grundgerüst einfach solide sein. Je höher man so ein Haus auftürmt, umso fester muss der Untergrund sein, auf dem es steht. Und nur durch Tests kriegt man wirklich einen festen Untergrund und die Sicherheit, noch ein Stockwerk oben drüber bauen zu können.
Ja, ich habe ja auch relativ viel getestet in den letzten Tagen. Es nimmt auch so recht kein Ende. Allerdings gibt es schon unterschiedliche Tests. Also bei mir ist es irgendwie der Test eher mit geht das überhaupt und trägt sich das dann so ein bisschen. Und ich denke, du sprichst vor allem Tests aus der Programmierwelt an.
Ja, das sind natürlich meine Lieblingstests. Das sind die, die automatisierbar sind. Aber ansonsten bin ich ziemlicher Technik-Skeptiker heutzutage geworden. Ich glaube erst dann, dass irgendetwas funktioniert, wenn ich es wirklich sehe. Ich glaube eigentlich niemanden, der mir erzählt irgendwas Technisches sei toll und würde funktionieren, bevor ich mich nicht mit eigenen Augen und Händen davon überzeugt habe.
Du hast vor ein paar Wochen sehr ausführliche Tests gemacht von Programmiersprachen. Kannst du das mal kurz umschreiben?
Na ja, ich habe eigentlich einen Micro-Benchmarking gemacht, allerdings in sehr, sehr vielen verschiedenen gängigen oder weniger gängigen Programmiersprachen, wobei ich die ganze Bandbreite von dynamischen Sprachen so wie angefangen bei Lua und Pearl über Lisp, Dillen, Scheme, Heißen...
Lass uns das nochmal kurz von vorne aufräumen. Also was du gemacht hast, waren Benchmarks. Das heißt, du hast eine Serie von Tests gemacht, die für dich einen gewissen normativen Charakter haben. Also du wendest sie gleichförmig auf alle Testobjekte an, auf derselben Maschine, also unter denselben Bedingungen. Und sie sollen natürlich auch eine gewisse Aussagefähigkeit haben über den täglichen Nutzwert. Was genau wolltest du testen?
Na, ich wollte die obere Grenze des Machbaren ermitteln. Das heißt, ich habe zunächst mal als aller simpelsten Test eine dichte Schleife, eine sogenannte Tight Loop genommen und gesehen, wie oft kann der Rechner eigentlich ein und dieselbe Anweisung wiederholen und dabei zählen. Eine ganz einfache Zählschleife. Und das eben von, wie gesagt, interpretierten Sprachen bis hin dann ganz oben, CC++ und Assembler.
Du hast ja alle, also du hast ja diese Tests, diese Benchmarks, die Mikro-Benchmarks. Warum nennst du sie Mikro-Benchmarks und nicht Benchmarks einfach nur?
Naja, viele Leute sagen, das seien keine richtigen Benchmarks und seien von keinerlei praktischer Bedeutung. Also Benchmarks selbst tobt ja grundsätzlich sowas wie einen Krieg. Die einen machen gerne anwendungsrelevante Benchmarks, also große Programme und Programmpakete, die eine typische Arbeitssituation und Funktionalität nachbilden. Das ist aber recht mühsam. Es ist unmöglich, so etwas wie Photoshop oder Word jetzt in zwölf verschiedenen Programmiersprachen zu programmieren.
Schon klar, du hast die Benchmarks selber programmiert, was natürlich verschiedene Vorteile hat, weil du ziemlich genau weißt, was sie exakt genau tun. Aber wie stehst du denn zu standardisierten Benchmarks, die gängigerweise ja immer wieder, vielleicht muss ich mal ein bisschen näher ans Mikrofon gehen, ich weiß es nicht so ganz genau, verunsichert mich dieser neue Audio-Setup. Also, wo war ich?
Bei den kommerziellen, den standardisierten Benchmarks.
So was wie MIPS zum Beispiel ist ja etwas, was man häufig hört. Ist ja auch irgendwie ein, na MIPS ist nicht wirklich ein Test. Was wollte ich sagen?
Ja, standardisierte, gängige Benchmarks, ja, Speckmark oder dann für, ich benutze für 3D-Karten zum Benchmark und für die CPU auch ganz gerne 3D-Mark, aber es gibt dann noch und ansonsten Zsoft Sandra unter Windows, das sind so die Benchmark-Programme und dann ansonsten ist meine Software, die ich selber schreibe, mit vielfältigsten Benchmark- und Profiling-Funktionen, bestückt und zwar so, dass nach jeder Änderung, die ich mache, automatisch alle Tests, da sind sie wieder, ausgeführt werden und außer, dass die richtigen Ergebnisse überprüft werden, bis hin zu ob die richtigen Bilder erzeugt wurden, werden auch die Laufzeitergebnisse gesammelt, sodass ich nicht nur sehen kann, dass das Programm die richtigen Ergebnisse liefert. Das merkt man nicht so schnell unter Umständen, weil beim manuellen Testen, ja, testet man nicht nicht immer wieder und wenn es mal 10 oder 20 Prozent länger dauert, fällt es einem menschlichen Tester sowieso nicht auf. Und deswegen gibt es auch so viel unglaublich langsame Software, weil ich glaube, dass wirklich Laufzeit-Tests während des laufenden Entwicklungsprozesses nur wenige machen bisher.
Das ist eine interessante Wahrnehmung, zum Beispiel bei Betriebssystemen ist, dass viele Leute bestimmten Betriebssystemen gegenüber so eine bestimmte Erwartungshaltung haben bezüglich ihrer Performance. Ich habe immer wieder festgestellt, dass unterschiedliche Gruppen über unterschiedliche Betriebssysteme ganz andere grundsätzliche Aussagen machen. Und man auch immer wieder merkt, das System ist an der Stelle am besten optimiert, wo es eben auch seine Zielgruppe hat. Das will man natürlich auch erwarten. Aber die Frage ist, ist es für möglich, dass man eben auch automatisierte Tests gegen Betriebssysteme fahren kann, bis hin vielleicht zur Benutzerschnittstelle, die einerseits ein Profiling ermöglicht. Das wird sicherlich machbar sein, das wird sicherlich auch getan, aber die dann eben auch wirklich ein Benchmarking für bestimmte Operationen erlauben. Also Fenster öffnen, Dokumente erstellen, speichern?
Benutzerschnittstelle ist sicher dann ein schwieriges Thema, wobei man natürlich sich überlegen könnte, dass man an eine Benutzerschnittstelle vielleicht dieselben Echtzeitanforderungen wie an ein Computerspiel stellt. Beim Computerspiel wird nun auch die Framerate angegeben. 60, 70, 80, 100 Hertz je nach Grafikkarte. Und eigentlich müsste oder wäre es schön, wenn das Betriebssystem nun auch in Echtzeit man sicher wäre, dass das User-Interface eben auch mit 60 Hertz beispielsweise läuft. Das heißt, das was ich auch mache, ich jede 60. Sekunde einen kompletten Bildaufbau mit dem aktuellen Zustand oder der aktuellen Veränderung einfach bekäme. Das wäre dann ein Snappy-Betriebssystem beispielsweise. Und ich wüsste auch nicht, warum das grundsätzlich nicht gehen sollte irgendwann mal.
Chaosradio Express, die Testsendung, das akustische Testbild. Wir versuchen es hier mit schwarzen und weißen Streifen und Farben in eure Köpfe Moiré-Muster zu erzeugen.
Ja und wir testen, wie das mit zwei Mikrofonen und zwei Menschen funktioniert.
Genau, der Aufbau dieses Systems ist durchaus interessant. Wir haben uns hier gerade während der Musik ein bisschen eine Pause gegönnt, darüber unterhalten, was wir jetzt hier eigentlich zu tun haben. Und der Testaufbau ist schon eine interessante, neuzeitliche Kombination, wie man sie sich vor ein paar Jahren bestenfalls wünschen könnte.
Tim, du konntest es kaum an dir halten vor Begeisterung.
Man muss das auch übersetzen können. Und es ist einfach möglich, mit relativ wenig Hardware schon sehr flexible Systeme zu machen. Was wir hier versuchen, ist einfach ein Radio-Studio zu bauen, also mit ganz großen Anführungsstrichen. Und es erfolgt halt einfach schließlich nur mit einem Laptop, einem USB-Midi-Controller und einem kleinen Lischpult und zwei Mikrofonen, die noch nicht mal gleicher Bauart sind, und Pavel hat auch keinen Kopfhörer, weil da fehlt der zweite Ausgang. Aber das ist alles relativ leicht nachzubessern. Das ist eine Frage des Geldes sozusagen. Aber die Gesamtkosten halten sich doch stark im Arm. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall können wir Einfluss nehmen. Genau, gucken wir da nochmal, was wir hier im Test haben. Dazu muss man, glaube ich, kurz... Das ist eine Testsendung, ich hab's gesagt. In der Testsendung darf man auch mal gegen das Mikrofon poltern. Also hier ist noch Record an.
Du hast gar nicht verraten, was für ein Produkt wir hier benutzen.
Das lasse ich alles im Geheimen und das dürfen dann alle raten. Und dann will ich das später nochmal erklären. Das muss man jetzt dramatisch... Ich kann's nicht lesen. Haben wir eigentlich schon Normalität erreicht? Ah, das war sie, die falsche Taste. Den hatten wir schon.
Da sind noch mehr Tasten.
Die muss ich nachher noch leiser machen.
Wir haben Normalität erreicht. Ich wiederhole, wir haben Normalität erreicht.
Alles, womit sie jetzt noch immer nicht fertig werden, ist folglich ihr Problem. Genau. Das war der Witz natürlich ein bisschen weg, aber so ist das nun mal beim Testen.
Unglaublich viele Knöpfe auf der Bildschirme und...
Also was hier passiert ist, die Software auf dem Rechner steuert das Geschehen. Es handelt sich dabei um Ableton Live, eine sehr interessante Software. Daneben steht ein USB-Midi-Controller, also so ein Gerät mit Reglern und Federn, wo man so rumdrehen kann. Und das fließt alles in die Software und ein kleines Mischpult, was sozusagen für die analoge Grundverkabelung sorgt. Und das ist eigentlich alles. Und die Mikrofone halt. Wie ist das jetzt für dich, der Sendung zu folgen, ohne einen Kopfhörer aufzuhaben?
Ja, es geht.
Komisch, oder?
Ja, es ist komisch, aber es geht. Es ist nicht wirklich ein Problem. Ich gucke hier gerade bei den Reglern. Ich finde es so gerne ein DS-er, ein DS-er. Ja, das ist das, was...
Pavel, wir kommen jetzt ein bisschen an den Kompressoreinstellungen herum. Wir sind beide noch etwas ratlos, aber nicht ohne Ahnung. Wir haben etwa eine Ahnung, was vielleicht weiterhelfen könnte.
Ich gehe jetzt mal etwas weiter runter mit dem Schwellwert hier, wo der anspricht.
Das muss natürlich jetzt sowohl für deinen als auch für meinen S gelten. Wir sind am gleichen Korneu.
Leider gibt es hier nichts, was die Ss heißt.
So, eins, zwei, drei.
Jetzt wäre natürlich ein Kopfhörer doch eine gute Sache.
Das stimmt. Wieso? Soll ich lauter reden? Ach so, du kannst es jetzt natürlich nicht so gut hören. Ich könnte dir natürlich mal, wir könnten ja mal kurz tauschen. Dann kriegst du meinen Kopfhörer. Und ich, upsala, ich muss jetzt, ähm, spreche ich lauter als du, ja, ne? Das musst du mir jetzt mal sagen. Soll ich das mal ein bisschen runter regeln? Ist das so besser?
Ja, ein bisschen runter.
Ein bisschen runter noch? So, ich will ja nicht vorlaut sein.
Da darf ich nämlich auch halten.
Jetzt wird es, glaube ich, langsam an der Zeit, mal die Uhrzeit durch zu sein.
So.
Wie spät ist es?
Nach drei oder nach vier.
Ja, es ist 20 vor vier.
So, jetzt vielleicht ein paar Esse. Hey, das funktioniert eigentlich schon ganz gut. Wir haben jetzt hier oberhalb von 800 Hertz.
Die Esse. Ich guck mal in der Wikipedia.
So, wenn ich den jetzt weiter oben...
Wunderwelt der Audio-Technik. Ich dachte ja immer, ich könnte einen großen Bogen drum rum machen, aber weit gefehlt.
Hier sind so komische Symbole, die ich nicht verstehe.
Wie würdest du D-S-H schreiben?
D-E-E-S-S-E-R.
Aha, Wikipedia findet Q-Base. Gleich hab ich auch einen. Ah, D-S-H mit großem E. Das ist übrigens ein Punkt an Wikipedia, der mich wirklich stört. Dass es erst mal diesen Zwang gibt zu den ersten großen Buchstaben, aber vor allem, dass die Suche dann nicht case-insensitiv sein kann. Dann könnte man es doch einfach schreiben, wie man will. Wobei soll ich wissen, dass man dann das zweite E groß schreiben muss.
Ja, das ist in der Tat sehr komisch.
Ansonsten ist es ja wirklich ein großartiges System. Aber so zwei, drei Dinge müssen echt nochmal...
Da war der D-S-S ganz gut beschrieben.
Ja, der D-S-S ist beschrieben, aber ich muss hier trotzdem erst mal einloggen an diesem Apparat, damit ich hier auch Spaß haben kann. Hier lege ich ein Konto an. Ah, jetzt verstehe ich es. Der Log-in-Screen hat sich geändert von der Wikipedia. Krass, der ist vereinfacht worden.
So, ich geb dir mal...
Ich hab sogar neue Nachrichten.
Deinen Kopfhörer wieder.
Ein Lexikon, was neue Nachrichten hat. Bin ich jetzt angemeldet oder was? Ja, bin ich. Dann... So, jetzt erst mal hier wieder die Sprachhaltung richtig einnehmen.
Du wolltest wieder zum DSer zurück.
Ich wollte wieder zum DSer zurück, das werde ich jetzt auch sofort tun.
Der Kopfhörer ist übrigens zu laut. Der Kopfhörer ist zu laut.
Na, aber da der jetzt aber genauso... Ach so, warte mal, dann mache ich das recht. Ich schieße mich auf die Boxen, aber ich wollte halt verhindern, dass wir hier...
Ja, Boxen brauche ich nicht, das ist kein Problem.
Nee, das Feedback aufs Mikrofon bekommen, dass es zu laut läuft. So, ich muss ja hier für beide runter regeln und deswegen da wieder ein bisschen umpassen. Okay, DSR schreibt sich also in Großes G, Kleines E, Großes E. ESR. Ein DSR ist ein Audioeffektgerät oder eine entsprechende Software, zum Beispiel ein VST-Plugin. Hier ist erlaubt, in der Tontechnik, die in einer Aufnahme von Sprache oder Gesang enthaltenen Zischlaute auch Simulanten im Pegel automatisch abzusenken. Zischlaute. Zischlaute sind im Übrigen noch nicht weiter erläutert. Da muss ich mir jetzt sozusagen was vorstellen drunter.
Doch, da unten kommt irgendwie...
Falls irgendjemand von euch weiß, was Zischlaute sind, in der Wikipedia gibt es da noch einen Artikel zu füllen.
Ja, es steht nur, sie bestehen ausschließlich aus solchen Frequenzen. Und werden durch das Verstärken dieser Bereiche überproportional laut wiedergegeben. Insofern klingen so eine so bearbeitete Aufnahme sehr unangenehm, da die Zischlaute zu laut wiedergegeben ausgesprochen aufdringlich herausknallen.
Jetzt erzeugst du wahrscheinlich genau wieder diesen Frequenzmangel bei der MP3-Herstellung, der im letzten Chaosradio so beklagt wurde. Okay, also das ist das, was ein DSer macht. Aber hat er auch eine Veranschaft zu einem Kompressor? Genau, hier. Falls ein DSer nicht im Effect-Rack, das sollte man eigentlich auch nochmal hier verlinken, zur Verfügung steht, kann man aus einem herkömmlichen Kompressor mit Sidechain-Eingang, das ist alles sehr modern hier, und einem herkömmlichen Equalizer selbst einen DSer zusammenstellen. Okay, aber wie? Das Ausgangssignal wird dabei über den Equalizer in den Sidechain-Eingang des Kompressors geschleift. Die Einstellungen des Equalizers stellen hier bei die Frequenzen der Zischlaute zur Verfügung ab, ca. 10 kHz anheben, den Rest absenken. Und ab Kompressor kann die Absenkung eingestellt werden. Das habe ich zwar nicht verstanden vom Lesen, aber ich glaube, wenn man eine Weile auf dieses kleine Modul startet... Okay, ich denke, das Thema haben wir jetzt auch erschöpfend behandelt.
Ja, klingt nicht besonders aufregend.
Es geht ja hier auch nicht um Kompressorkonfiguration, sondern ums Testen. Was haben wir denn noch nicht getestet jetzt? Also, die Aufnahme läuft noch. Das sieht doch eigentlich ganz prima aus.
Ja, vielleicht haben wir auch... Gibt es sonst noch irgendwas zu Tests zu sagen? Dann könnten wir vielleicht auch mal mit dem Testen aufzuhören.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Ja, Tests.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich mal einen tollen Test gemacht habe. Ich bin eigentlich nicht so ein Testtyp. Also zumindest habe ich mir noch keine automatisierten Tests geschrieben. Auch nicht für meine Programme. Aber ansonsten, ich teste immer ganz gerne. Ich probiere immer gerne aus.
Ja, und die meisten Dinge funktionieren leider heutzutage nicht richtig, weil zu wenig Zeit zum Testen allgemein genommen wird.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Diese fortschreitende, wir müssen nochmal was tolles Neues rausbringen, führt manchmal einfach nicht dazu, dass irgendetwas überhaupt noch eine passende Reife erfährt. Aber das kann ich mir auch wiederum nicht vorstellen. Letzten Endes setze ich ja sowieso immer nur das durch, was die Leute auch wirklich... Was siehst du, was für einen Test brauchen wir denn zum Beispiel? Nehmen wir doch mal ein anderes komplexes Gebilde. Nehmen wir doch mal die Gesellschaft. Angenommen, man müsste jetzt diese Gesellschaft benchmarken. Man könnte halt irgendwie einen Standard-Benchmark nehmen. Das ist wahrscheinlich so was wie so eine Umfrage.
Das wird ja ständig gemacht.
Genau, das wird die ganze Zeit gemacht. Die werden auch immer wieder zitiert. Weise sprechen dann auf einmal zu einem und zeigen einem die wirtschaftliche Zukunft voraus, weil sie irgendwelche Schlaubkerne aufgelesen haben beim Sonnenuntergang. Aber welchen Test müsste man sozusagen einführen, um diese Gesellschaft zu microbenchmarken, um wirklich so auf den niedrigsten Operationsebene die Dinge zu finden, die jetzt verstopft sind, so ähnlich wie bei einer anderen Software? Oder ist das ein unangemessener Vergleich?
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Frage, über die ich mir noch nie im Leben vorher Gedanken gemacht habe. Aber wir können ja ein bisschen rumspekulieren. Das eine wäre vielleicht irgendwie die Begeisterungsfähigkeit einer Gesellschaft. Wobei, wie will man die messen? Also ein mögliches Maß wäre, wie viele Tausend Menschen man auf einmal an denselben Ort bekommt, um irgendetwas zu tun oder irgendetwas zu erleben. Das wäre vielleicht ein möglicher Benchmark. Ich weiß nicht, ob da unser Land besonders gut abschneidet. Obwohl der Papst, als der Papst da war, da sind doch irgendwie anderthalb Millionen Menschen. Also die Kirche scheint nach dem zu gehen.
Es gibt Begeisterung. Es wird auch hier im nächsten Jahr große Begeisterung geben. Die Frage ist, ob das wirklich ein angemessener Benchmark ist, ausgedacht, dann die Fühler auszustrecken, wenn gerade eine Fußballweltmeisterschaft im Lande ist.
Die Frage ist, ob zur Fußballweltmeisterschaft werden da mehr Besucher kommen als zum Papst.
Jetzt muss ich dich noch mal kurz unterbrechen, bevor ich den Gedanken aufnehme, weil wir haben jetzt gerade ein Problem mit unserem Test, weil die Musik ist abgerissen.
Quasseln wir, testen wir schon so lange?
Na ja, die ist eigentlich länger, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist das Ding nicht in seiner vollen Länge importiert worden. Das wäre jetzt immer eine erste Vermutung. Aber ich kann ja immer eine andere Musik drauflegen.
Während das so läuft, während wir hier jetzt die Sendung machen, wo stellst du hier jetzt an der Konfiguration von dem ganzen Ding rum?
Du meinst, wir dürfen das nur testen, aber nicht konfigurieren?
Keine Ahnung. Das wäre interessant, ob du jetzt eigentlich während das Ding so spielt da jetzt einen neuen Track reinziehst.
Ja, das sollte mir schon gelingen. Du musst mal kurz es noch weiter erläutern.
Während Tim jetzt neue Musik sucht...
Das wird jetzt sehr interessant zu sehen, ob dieser Effekt, den vielleicht nur wir gerade gehört haben, vielleicht habt ihr ihn auch gehört. Ich hoffe, ihr habt ihn auch gehört. Ich vermute auch mal.
Das ist irgendein Geist, ein Spuk in Tims Rechner.
Es ist unglaublich. Ich habe eine Vermutung, was es ist. Aber erst, wenn das auch in der Aufzeichnung drauf ist, werde ich darüber spekulieren.
Ich weiß, was es ist. Es ist einfach dein Betriebssystem, das aus irgendwelchen Gründen sich geweigert hat, oft genug an der Grafikkarte vorbeizukommen, um den Audiopuffer wieder zu füllen. Deswegen wurde für mehrere Sekunden derselbe Audiopuffer immer wieder abgespielt, weil das die Hardware macht. So, da kommt jetzt neue Musik. Wir nehmen immer noch auf.
Und wir nehmen immer noch auf, ja ja. Jetzt haben wir halt die Pause hier auch schön. Das ist einfach ein sehr interessantes Zeitdokument.
Ich finde, das Tool macht tatsächlich einen echt brauchbaren Eindruck.
Das ist echt der Hammer. Schon lange nicht mehr so ein gutes User-Interface gesehen. Ich bin schwer beeindruckt.
Ja, das sieht gut aus und du sagtest, Berliner stecken dahinter?
Genau, das ist die Firma Ableton. Die kommen aus Berlin. Ich kenne die zwar nicht, aber ich glaube, ich muss mit denen mal unterhalten. Aber die Musik ist da, es funktioniert einfach. Und ich habe auch echt den Eindruck, dass das aufnimmt. Wir werden es natürlich erst später sehen, aber es sieht schwer danach aus. So, das Kapitel mit dem DSR, das kann man jetzt schließen. Wir waren bei dem Gesellschaftstest angekommen. Das Mikro-Benchmark für die Gesellschaft im Zustand der großen Koalition.
Es gibt gerade einen Asimov, der hat einen anderen Benchmark gegeben, nämlich den Energieverbrauch. Die Menge an Energie, die eine Gesellschaft pro Person verbraucht, ist ein Maß für ihre zivilisatorische Entwicklung. Danach werden die Amerikaner ganz weit vorne, weil die blasen zwischen zwei und vier Mal so viel Energie pro Jahr raus wie ein Deutscher.
Ich hab den Gain total aufgerissen, der rauscht wahrscheinlich mehr als es soll, aber man kann es auch entspannter halten. Ist schon okay.
Passt schon. Ja, viel zu laut.
Wenn das jetzt die bequeme Position ist für dich, dann kann ich das ja so regeln. Ich muss sagen, ich hab früher immer unterschätzt den Arbeitsaufwand, den man hätte, wenn man keinen guten Tontechniker hat. Ich hab den Trouble unterschätzt. Weil die ja immer da sind und alles funktioniert einfach mal. Merkt ihr mal erst, wenn es nicht funktioniert.
Ja, aber die haben da ganz dicke Geräte, die irgendwie 50 Mal so viel kosten, wie das, was hier auf dem Schreibtisch steht. Und die falten die Stimme schon so. Und hügeln und weichspülen die, dass da nun jeder so klingt, fast jeder zumindest, als hätte er eine brauchbare Stimme.
So, das funktioniert doch ganz gut. Ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung, wie ich den Lautstärkeunterschied hier im Allgemeinen einschätzen soll. Das ist alles gerade ganz schwierig hier mit diesem Mikro- und Lautsprecher-Setup. Aber das ist ja auch egal. Wo waren wir denn jetzt stehengeblieben bei unseren Gesellschaftern? Also die Energie, der Energieverbrauch. Und meinst du, das ist schon ein brauchbarer Benchmark?
Du hattest ja nach Micro-Benchmarks gefragt. Und ja, eigentlich Energieverbrauch ist vielleicht ein ganz brauchbarer Benchmark dafür. Man kann natürlich jetzt...
Wird der, sagen wir mal, für deine Ansprüche auch schon ausreichend erfasst? Meine Zahlen, die heute so kommen, kommen von wo her?
Ah, da gibt es in Deutschland eine riesige Bürokratie, die das alles verfasst, die Statistischen Landeskünfte. Und jeder Unternehmer ist verpflichtet, zum Beispiel seitenlang Informationen über, ja, eben statistische Informationen zu geben. Und ansonsten gibt es jede Menge private, staatliche Organisationen, die sich mit dem Thema beschäftigen. Und auch jeder Staat hat bestimmte Zahlen, einfach abzuliefern, die er erhebt. Nee, da gibt es sicher jede Menge.
Ja gut, aber die Frage ist, was kann man jetzt damit aussagen? Jetzt haben wir hier halt mehr und da haben wir weniger Energie. Worüber kann man damit wirklich eine, also was, worüber kann man danach eine Aussage fassen, die man vorher nicht konnte?
Was die Gesellschaft in der Lage ist, in Bewegung zu setzen oder umzusetzen. Weil natürlich kann man jetzt einwenden, die verschwenden die Energie, aber die müssen die Energie ja irgendwie beschaffen und bezahlen. Das heißt, wenn sie so viel Energie verbrauchen, müssen sie auch irgendetwas, einen Mechanismus dahinter haben, der es ihnen ermöglicht, an so viel Energie ranzukommen. Und diesen Mechanismus haben die Amerikaner offenbar. Und der ist vermutlich sehr vielfältig und nicht immer zur Freude und zum Nutzen aller anderen Völker auf dieser Welt.
Zumindest ist er sehr flexibel. Wenn man sich anschaut, welchen Schaden eigentlich allein die Ölinfrastruktur im Golf genommen hat durch die ganzen fortgesetzten Hurricane-Disaster. Der Preis hat sich immer ein bisschen geändert, aber ansonsten ist eigentlich nicht viel passiert. Hier ist er halt auch teurer geworden, weil dann eben auch die Reserven aus Europa abgezogen wurden. Mein Kenntnis stand nach.
Keine Ahnung, wie schlimm das wirklich da drüben war, aber ich glaube doch, dass für eine ganze Menge Menschen das eine traumatische Erfahrung gewesen sein muss, vor einer leeren Tankstelle zu stehen. Und egal für wie viel Geld, einfach den Tank nicht füllen zu können. Und das ist ein lebensbedrohlicher Zustand in den USA, weil da kann man nicht eben mal in den Bus steigen. Oder in den Zug. Es gibt einfach Gegenden. Sie ist ja der wilde Westensee vom Rücken des Pferdes ausgebaut. Und aus dem Planwagen, das mag mir ein Stück weit stimmen, aber versorgt wird er aus dem Kofferraum der amerikanischen Automobile. Wir sind schon wieder vom Thema Tests abgekommen. Aber zum Testen, es funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut. Man kann auch recht entspannt plaudern. Man tendiert natürlich jetzt so in diesem Zweierformat, wo man hier sitzt, sehr viel zum Reden. Also wir müssten eigentlich mehr Pausen machen.
Das stimmt, also machen wir doch mal einen. Ha, jetzt wird's spannend. Wir haben jetzt gerade den Defekt wieder gehört. Mal schauen, ob der nachher wieder dabei ist. So, da sind wir wieder und wir haben beschlossen, dass es genug des Testens gewesen ist, aber es hat viel Spaß gemacht. Warte mal, wir haben die Musik zu laut, zack, genau, das war das. Ja, das war eine live produzierte Testsendung. Total ungeplant.
Mit Tests über Tests.
Genau und untests herum. So, was bleibt uns jetzt noch? Jetzt bleibt uns eigentlich nur noch...
43? Vielleicht eine Minute können wir ja noch füllen jetzt. Vielleicht hast du nicht noch irgendeinen interessanten Jingle, den wir noch nicht gehört haben, den Knopf auf.
Ja, aber jetzt muss ich erstmal hier die Jingle-Geschichte noch mal ein bisschen leiser machen, sonst fetzt es mir wieder die Ohren weg.
Aber das geht doch nachträglich auch noch, oder?
Na ja, das ist ja kein richtiger Test...
.die Ohren schon weg, ja, das stimmt.
Ah, die anderen sind natürlich auch so knallig laut.
Ja.
Die muss ich aber jetzt auch wieder über einen Knopf abrufen. Ah nee, hatte ich den nicht schon vorhin als... Vorhin hab ich den schon fälschlicherweise abgespielt, dann hab ich ihn eigentlich auch schon verraten.
Ja, den dritten gab's auch noch nicht, oder?
Nee, den gab's noch nicht, den sparen wir uns glaube ich noch ein bisschen auf. Mal noch mal ein bisschen gucken. Also, richtige Taste müsste eigentlich diese Taste sein. Und natürlich vorher noch mal die Musik runterziehen.
Ja, ich sehe, es gibt noch ein Problem mit diesem Setup möglicherweise. Wo gehen denn jetzt die Mikrofone eigentlich rein?
Die Mikrofone gehen hier in das analoge Mischpult rein.
Meine Sprache, geht die auf beide Stereokanäle erst mal raus oder geht jeweils einer von uns hier auf dem linken und der andere auf dem rechten Kanal rein?
Nee, das wird hier gemischt, aber das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Das hatte ich noch gar nicht ausprobiert. Wir können uns nämlich jetzt eigentlich auch verteilen. Das müsste ich jetzt hier am analogen Mischpult machen, weil da gehen die Mikrofone zusammen.
Der Hintergrund wäre nämlich der, dass dann die Sprache...
Warte mal, irgendwas geht hier noch nicht so ganz, wie ich mir das so vorstelle. Da hab ich nur gerade rausgedreht.
Also ich bin noch drin hier und du? Eins, zwei, drei.
Warte mal, ich kann dich auch rausdrehen. Oder? Jetzt höre ich dich nicht. Jetzt hab ich dich gerade rausgedreht.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Warte mal, das verstehe ich noch nicht so ganz. Ok, live dokumentiert, ich verstehe nicht die Bedeutung dieser blöden PAN-Regler.
Aber das kommt hier auch irgendwie...
Eigentlich sind die genau dafür gedacht, links, rechts den Anteil zu verteilen.
1, 2, 3...
Das kriege ich jetzt alles nicht auf die Reihe. Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt einfach schon zu müde.
Ja, aber das wäre auf jeden Fall gut, um dann bei den zwei Mikrofonen die Lautstärke unterschiedlich anzupassen. Je nachdem, bei jeder von uns hält das Mikrofon wahrscheinlich anders. Das können wir natürlich jetzt leider nicht mehr.
Also es gibt noch so viel zu testen, unendliche Weiten auszuprobieren.
Unendlich viele Tests.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, vielen Dank Pavel, für die spontane Mitternachts-Show.
Wo ich eigentlich schon im Bett sein sollte.
Und ich erst.
Schon längst. Das werde ich auch jetzt gleich tun.
Okay, ich auch. Und so bleibt uns nur noch Tschüss sagen. Das war Chaosradio Express, die unerwartete Test-Sendung. Und ich weiß, das war die Musik vom letzten Mal, aber das war ja schließlich auch nur ein Test.